the recent sanctions against russia were
meant to [ __ ] the country after they
invaded ukraine the united states many
european countries and all of nato they
came together and they said we've got to
punish these people for what they're
doing and ultimately those sanctions
they're financial in nature they try to
cut off russia its citizens and its
leadership from the global financial
system but there's one big problem
russia is one of the largest producers
of energy resources in the entire world
if we look at this chart here you can
see here that the united states yearly
gas production is the only country in
the world that's larger than russia
russia is also one of the largest
exporters of natural gas and oil across
the globe and so naturally what ends up
happening is that there are many many
countries who have given up energy
independence and they quite literally
are dependent on russia and those
resources russia saw this as an
opportunity and they stepped in and they
said starting april 1st
you will have to pay us in rubles
instead of dollars or any other currency
the whole idea behind this was that
paying in rubles wouldn't actually
violate the sanctions of the eu nato or
the us
and also would require more and more
countries to adopt russia's native
currency now naturally there's plenty of
people who said they're not gonna do it
no way jose countries like poland and
bulgaria they completely refused to use
rubles to buy these energy resources and
now the news is breaking that at least
four different european gas buyers have
already paid for supplies in rubles and
10 european companies have already
opened the accounts at that russian gas
producer needed to meet putin's payment
demands now this is an absolutely crazy
scenario to see all these companies that
have become dependent on russian oil and
natural gas having to open up ruble
accounts and literally paying in rubles
as well not exactly what many people
thought would be happening in 2022 but
here we are and so now moving forward
the question is what exactly is russia's
next move well russia has come out and
they're publicly stating that they're
going to cut off even more people from
their natural resources they're not
going to sell any more natural gas or
oil to buyers who don't pay in rubles
the kremlin says that russia is a
reliable energy supplier and it doesn't
engage in blackmail lol the kremlin says
buyers of russian energy were notified
well in advance of new payment terms now
ultimately this is exactly what you
would expect if the united states nato
or other countries around the world all
start to step up and levy financial
sanctions against russia there's other
countries who are just going to say look
i don't agree with what they're doing in
ukraine but i need the natural gas i
need the oil whatever the payment terms
are we are going to adhere to them
because we need the resources for our
citizens and so lastly if we take a look
as russia continues to say that more gas
buyers are going to have to pay in
rubles or risk getting cut off we can
also see that european gas prices are
already up 24
and the ruble has just reached a
two-year high against the euro
regardless of what you think about
russia about vladimir putin or the
situation in ukraine it's very obvious
that russia believes that they have
found some level of leverage here and
they're going to exploit it and the big
question is how much pain can european
countries the united states or others
around the world sustain before they
give in to these new payment terms and
they start to use rubles my guess is
that it's not actually going to be
global adoption of the ruble but there's
plenty of companies who say i don't care
what i need to pay it give me the gas
and give me the oil because literally my
people need it hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time